anyone that you particularly had like
really tough days against
check
no
Joe Hart
vanasar always scored against him
hi I'm Jermaine Defoe and this is my
fives on sport Bible
so goalkeeper
I'm gonna go with Hugo loris
when he actually knew Hugo before he
came to Tottenham I met him in a suffer
France and I remember I was playing like
um
this like Head tennis on a beach with
him and I remember thinking wow like for
a goalkeeper with his feet it was
unbelievable or surprised so when I
found out he was coming to Tottenham you
can imagine I was buzzing I'd send all
the players that I said Hugo's top like
um you know he's so good with his feet
and when it comes to Tottenham what
really impressed me is how quick it was
around a goal because it's not massive
to be fair you wouldn't say Hugo's got
big presence in that but he was just
slacking electric around the goal quick
off his line World Cup winner
so yeah we'd recommend going one at the
back what are you saying okay that's
easy
not the king literally had everything
and it was unfortunate to be fair
because
he had all the injuries so he never
trained he never trained like you see
Lady Junior like throughout the week and
that he'd be on the bike on a Friday he
might go out and have a jog on a
Saturday get man the match it was
unbelievable and I remember Terry on
recent I think it was after one of the
Euros maybe 2004. Tierra actually said
he's he's one of the best defenders ever
played against um in terms of a Defender
like an all-round you talk about the
modern game you know Defenders that can
defend that can run that can pass that
can tackle like he had everything but
just unfortunate with injuries I think
if you speak to any top Defender you
speak to Rio JT they all say that
Neddy's one of the best
easy
Nuka Modric
what was it about Luca
Alan we got I remember we played against
Croatia for England Stevie Lance played
um he's got this little guy Midfield and
I remember just thinking wow this guy's
special
um just like so silky with a ball never
lost the ball could receive the ball in
anyone a pitch you just knew then that
he was going to be like um you know
world-class player then obviously a play
with him at Tottenham for a few years
again it just made the game look easy
everything went through Luca and
obviously a Ballon d'Or winner and
obviously everything they achieved at
Madrid it's just uh he's definitely one
of the best players I've played with but
that's an easy one
Luca Modric
okay read that
Michael Carrick wow what a player
see Michael I play with Michael in the
youth team we're Stan I just remember
being a youth team like he just did
everything that the game asked you to do
and if anything's simple you know if he
got the ball and and you should pass
here he would pass there you know if if
somebody's on it you should play long
you'll play long but just these Ranger
passing
was so special and I think to be honest
I don't think he gets I don't think he
gets enough credit but just for like a
complete midfielder
um definitely won the best I played with
but it's just crazy how he didn't get
more England caps obviously it was just
unfortunate because he's got you've got
Stevie and lamps who at the time was at
the top of their game but but you know
what a player so you got Hugo you got
letters these two that can play actually
someone that's going to score on it
really
so I've got you've obviously I've got
Robbie
Berbatov
even when I was younger like I played
with les
Sharma AJ
foreign
as a young kid
I'm 16 at the time and I remember every
day just watching him I'd ask loads of
questions the stuff he like what he
would do when he goes home he was always
on a massage bed for like for two hours
before training after the way he lived
his life you know even days off that
he'd always be in remember being the
youth team in that and then we'd be
training and I can always see Palo just
jogging on his own and it was like one
first team player in us and there's no
coincidence how he was always the best
player on a weekend just a genius I
think he did the goals that he scored
but yeah
I think that's a good team you know
anyone that you particularly had like
really tough days against
check
no
Joe Hart
vanasar always scored against him
[Laughter]
I think there's someone who I played
against and played with
I remember speaks a lot of players about
Davey James and a lot of players have
said the same but on his day
was he made the goal look so small
and it was just like an unbelievable
athlete even in training as well I
remember we used to do a lot of
finishing and training and it was it was
always hard to beat him I just felt like
he had everything is gets around the
goal quick
he had that presence where he could die
he could come for crosses just that
complete athlete and it was I think it
was a lot different to goalkeepers I've
probably played against at the time when
I first come through and played with
what was it about
John Terry in particular do you know
what it was just like she's a proper
Defender when you play against people
like that you know you have to be on it
um to get any sort of chance to score
to me if I could have put I could have
put Rio
I could put Soul Campbell I played
against Martin keown
um I'll probably get I played against
muscle Desai but I think with JT he had
everything he could defend tackle head
it it basically it would run for a brick
wall for the team you know even like
little things like um with movements
like he was really clever because I
always think that sometimes we send it
forwards like the defender has to go off
your movement so you're in control most
of the time you know because you know if
the ball goes wide I'm looking to get
across an air pose but he always knew so
he was sort of like blocking an air post
and it was really clever and it's almost
like he spent a lot of time with the
center forwards that he played with and
just probably asked questions like we
did with a drug version like the
all these players are all the top Center
full Chef shenko all these world-class
Center forsy played with almost like he
spent a lot of time answering questions
on that because I always felt like
everyone you made it's like he knew so
you had to bring a little bit more
I mean I could speak all day about
Stevie I always say everything he did
was so aggressive like he's passing he's
running
tackling head everything he did was just
like so aggressive and explosive he was
definitely one that could sort of like
just dictate a whole game you know could
score goals could create goals could
probably play as a six good players are
eight players or ten could play as a
number nine
um could probably play here because you
could tackle as well you know but yeah
on his day it's all about
players at their Peak I mean if you're
planning to get Stephen Gerrard then
good good luck
front lamp pod
and what's the lamps bring into that
team just bringing goals
go to Midfield 20 goals because they've
been playing against lamps sometimes you
know like
you see him in that you think oh he's
having a quiet game and all of a sudden
the comes out to you as of the
box
20 yards 30 yards and he just he just it
was just ping in the top corner and I
don't believe there's many mid folders
that can do that I think especially now
if you look if you look at football now
how many midfielders you get
that one even like kids really you go
you go to Academy games there's not a
lot of kids that shoot from distance
because everyone wants to play you know
you talk about passing patterns and
everyone wants to you know the ball
comes here and they pass it wide or they
you know they just pop they go back and
they turn out so Frank Lampard will drop
it out teenage box he's just he was just
smashing the top corner
Thierry Henry
do I need to explain
[Laughter]
you know physically it was so gifted
um because not not often you see players
that are that big
and that could run
it's got skills that can finish
um
I just felt like he was just completely
different to anything I'd seen before I
remember I was young I was time actually
we played at Highbury played against
Arsenal and I scored early in the game
end up losing three one I think it was
I remember saying to him like can I have
your shirt off that again you know
you're a young player the game finished
then we went back in into the change
room so I probably thought I thought I
sat therefore I forgot but there was a
knock on the door and he came in
actually gave me a shirt like wrote a
long message and I was like wow that was
unbelievable so
Not only was it that obviously it's a
special player in that but I never
forget what he'd done there because it
was like um yeah a good guy in that but
just just completely just different to
what I've seen before yeah I just feel
like he had everything probably the best
player that we've seen the Premier
League in my opinion so if if that match
were to happen the team that you played
with versus the team that you played
against who's winning that and how's it
going
gotta be careful this answer on it
obviously well I'd want
I'd want this team to win
Etc
and then and then penalties and then
which again is not reading in it and
which team would you prefer to play for
what are you doing to me
I could moan at Luca
because he was quite chilled
it's buggy that's who's according
yeah I don't come from like new team
sponge I could probably moan at him
because he never he never moaned of
course anything to him
it was mad he was quite as well lit
this team's special in it
probably playing this team to be fair
[Music]
vir would have ruled out Peter Crouch's
goal versus Trinidad and Tobago in 2006.
[Laughter]
you can't go pulling dreadlocks yeah
welcome